summer is home to some of the best
movies ever just think back on some of
your favorite summer movies
like there's a lot of them and here's a
brand new one
to add to your list my name is guy
sunday should be warm and sunny just a
scattering of drive-bys
and i live in paradise
cheryl is coming to us live from
vacation i was gonna say
cheryl is somewhere not working except
for the next four
minutes i follow her on instagram like
she's on vacation right
okay i bribed my husband with beer and
the children with sugar to be here
i mean the movie is that good it's the
first time i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
you're really bringing families together
when you think most kids were like i
want to see deadpool we can't let you
see deadpool and then you made free guy
and it's a movie that we can all see
together did you do that on purpose no
it had nothing to do with that as much
as i just really wanted to tell the
story
we never wanted to make just a video
game movie i did want to make a movie
that would be as warm as it was funny
and
when you can combine those two elements
those laughs
and those touching moments and do it in
a story that is appropriate
for us to watch with our kids and our
parents
you know we didn't set out to do that
but it
thrills me whenever something i've made
can bring
families together i got like five
percent of that we're talking about
superheroes and super powers what would
you say ryan
sean are your super powers you know
years ago
this is sort of weird but interesting i
took a conflict resolution
workshop and man oh man that changed my
life like it really allowed me to kind
of communicate
in ways with p with people who were not
easy to communicate with
so that i would say it was a bit of a
superpower and a bit of a kind of a hack
uh in my everyday life i want to comply
i just find the order of those threats
very cute somebody's about to get [ __ ]
mine would probably be an interpersonal
superpower too i bounce around a lot
but if i'm talking to you i'm gonna be
right here with you and i'd say that
that's been a bit of a an ability i
don't know if it's a superpower but it's
an ability that served me with he's like
tom cruise when he's talking to you it's
laser focus
that is true it's like i'm seeing into
your soul yeah
wouldn't it be great if all the best
summer entertainment was in one place
well it is check it out at etcanada.com
dq
brought to you by the new dq summer
blizzard treat menu featuring oh henry
peanut butter
dq happy tastes good